[Music]
one thing that you got to be careful of
is you fidget and the I I can't hear you
fidgeting on the call but I can hear you
fidgeting in the recording
yes I'm aware of my fidgetiness is that
a is that a thing it's like a stimming
helps you focus I don't know I it's just
like uh are you just so passionate about
the idea yeah I'll go with that one no
I'm [__] I'm so fidgety I'm always if
you if you just watch me I move so much
more than normal people do I don't know
what it is it's kind of nervous disorder
Eric is a bright and insightful child
but I encourage him to sit in his desk
and keep his hands to himself or we are
going to have to medicate him ADHD baby
hi listener
uh if you are a filthy casual you might
not have heard from us in a bit but if
you do patronize us
you
will have heard our David Graber and the
other David episodes
we did a post-modernism
episode you know the David Graber book
has really stuck in my head you know
that dawn of everything when you when
you read something in an academic
context you kind of most of the time
forget about it but every once in a
while one of them like sticks in your
head Twilight of the idols by Nietzsche
is another book that always sticks in my
head but I've been finding since we read
it that one has uh
when they say everyone thinks this and
you're like well I'm not really sure
that everyone thinks that but then uh
you metaphorically step out of your door
which means unlocking your phone let's
be real but then everyone is saying the
thing that he's saying everyone says and
then it you're okay David's it do be
like that the Age of Empires picture of
history as we called it ah yeah yeah
it's like they think they all exist on
the media sphere it's weird yeah you go
you talk to people out on the street
they're like yeah yeah we probably we
understand that the picture is probably
more complicated than that but then yeah
so anyway that was uh pillpod 127. this
is pillpod 130.
and it is only myself and yourself Eric
Tate's self and me
Victor is off getting a tan at the
cottage
you know to people who are not in
Ontario they're when we say we're going
to the cottage there's a lot of lakes
north of the urban sprawl that is
Toronto and the city's attached to
Toronto but up up where all the little
Lakes are
going to the cottage means driving north
and getting an Airbnb on the lake unless
your friend has Rich parents that that's
always a bonus they own a place up there
yeah but you know Eric in BC no one says
Cottage I never heard that until I came
here we say the cabin oh the cabin yeah
yeah I could see that
I wonder what the difference is because
the first time I heard torontonian
saying we're going to the cottage the
signif the signified of the cottage to
me is like a fairy tale thing like
little Little Red Riding Hood's Grandma
has a cottage but if you're going to the
if you're going to the lake you're going
to the cabin
yeah cabin feels more Outback like it
covers more uh just back country kind of
situations and made of logs a cottage I
I could expect it to be made of stone or
brick
or even like little siding houses like
that you could call them a cottage I
think Cottage just has a kind of a wider
application
but then yeah you guys say cabin instead
of cottage so I don't know well I assume
as the as the language evolved back in
the day there would have been many more
cabins on the west coast in the Pacific
Northwest so maybe that's picturing log
cabins like a giant made out of giant
redwood trees
like New Yorkers say I'm going Upstate
right they don't even mention the the
building oh God don't quiz me on that I
have no idea okay well anyway Victor's
not here that's the point uh would you
like to talk any [__] about Victor while
he's gone we have to we can air some air
some grievances
well I mean this this connects to last
week's article that that he he wanted us
to read what we're going to be doing
today because one of the key terms of
that one was bio cultures and this this
week we're talking about nature cultures
and he does exactly I think the the
article that we looked at last week does
exactly what this text we are reading
says not to do
which is to make an asymmetrical
distinction between nature and human
culture
non-human nature and human culture and
then you distribute unevenly properties
to both of those separate containers of
things and so he does exactly that he
finishes he goes on talking about body
cultures and how biology and politics
are intertwined and then he goes but we
must distinguish the human from other
animals and then by Fiat Deus Ex Machi
now we're back in Liberal politics but
with a little bit of evolutionary
biology yeah we're not doing that he
kind of reconstitutes the uh the uh the
modernist Constitution there yeah the
way that's that's that's my own I talk
[__] about the article that he chose but
I mean there's some great swipes at
liberalism here too so yeah this is the
post-humanist side of the podcast and we
are doing a post-humanist reading
something that actually just gets Eric
off it's
one of his favorite authors well why
don't we just talk about it we pick
something that we like I think I've our
very first episode ever on this podcast
was on this guy not this book
but the book is we have never been
modern
Bruno LaTour
does science know anything
uh is he alive still let me just check
no he died he died quite recently
actually oh [__] he died last year
yeah very recently
no not kovid dude so many of the French
homies we've gone through they died
during covid but none of them actually
from Co like Stiegler uh Jean-Luc donci
Michelle said oh God yeah yeah that's
like that whole generation LaTour cites
Sarah definitely he uh wow yeah
or seres as it's as it as it looks on
paper to anglophones you know who never
[__] dies is habermas
soon should we celebrate his 1 millionth
birth the German theorists they just
live long maybe because they uh they
smoke less like gautamer died when he
was 104 or some [__] yeah maybe a diet a
diet thing I don't know Hopper Mass
maybe maybe
uh Centris just live longer who knows
they should do they should do some kind
of study because habermas did kind of
pull back from the uh more radical
attitude of the Frankfurt School yeah
that's probably what g-jack's trying to
do this week yeah pull to the center so
you can pump out another uh another
couple years well I'm looking at this
list you just sent me which is what is
it called the humanities citation
ranking so I guess in terms of
popularity these are the most
most cited theorist types and Humanities
social sciences and art Scholars
yeah so kind of no surprise uh Foucault
Michelle Foucault is number one top of
the dog pile
I was shocked to see here uh Bruno
LaTour is number 10th
yeah ahead of such figures as Sigmund
Freud and Emmanuel Kant and Martin
Heidegger
and I was disappointed to see that
Nietzsche is in like 37th yeah
Marx 36 yeah we got old David Harvey out
there yeah Karl Marx and Nietzsche are
pulling up the bottom just just below
Jack Lacon and Thomas [__] yeah I I've
seen other rankings in like Noam Chomsky
cleans up in the in some of the other
rankings though
yeah here we got Noam Chomsky speaking
of someone who won't die he's at a 15
here
yeah but the top 10 are Foucault
Borgia that's kind of
interesting to see
um Dairy da number three
um some psychologists Ben Dura and
Gideons who I've never heard of Irvin
Goffman habermas at number seven
1929 Dash it does not have his date of
death yet
um Weber at eight
Judith Butler at nine and Bruno LaTour
rounding out at number 10. yeah this is
a Humanities ranking index there's
many different ways to measure these
sorts of things I'm not really sure if
the parameters of this one imagine it's
kind of internal to philosophy sociology
psychology anthropology and Etc
yeah it looks like academic citations
rather than like New York Times
citations it appears that way Barts yeah
I mean yeah I've heard of I've heard of
I've at least heard of of all these
people
George lackoff too we talked about him
the other day the the metaphors we live
by Guy
all right so if we're turning to uh the
topic
we have never been modern and this does
not mean we've never been modern in The
Tick Tock sense I have to tell you about
this I I'm sure you haven't seen it
because you are you're you're deserting
rather than uh browsing but Tick Tock
there was a a thing I think it's a few
months old but I just found out about it
it's the funniest thing we were at one
time modern and we used to interpret the
world scientifically you know that's the
story
but Tick Tock is causing people to
revert to like primitive animism
so if you see the mirror trend on tick
tock
oh God no what is it you have to you
have to copy someone else's movements is
that no no it's it's much worse it's
much worse than you could imagine it's
you take a piece of you take a piece of
paper
and you put it on the mirror and then
you put something you know on your side
of the piece of paper and then they move
the camera to where to the mirror and
then they can see the object in the
mirror and freak out like oh my God how
can the mirror see that because there's
no direct light lines to oh to the
Mirror yeah yeah
and they wonder how you can see it
because the Zoomers of course believe
that the mirror is a screen projection
as a phone screen so it has its own
perspective because phones do and phones
are all they know they don't understand
that no the light is bouncing from the
object to the mirror to your eye
and they go one of them I think this one
had to be a joke but the
the little writing on the tick tock was
like mirrors how do they know
and this spiraled off into mirrors are a
separate Universe which I believe is the
premise of a Borges short story The
Mirror people are gonna return one day
so they just the theory is that light
only bounces at 90 degree angles and
nothing else yes this is an unintended
consequence of having smartphones is we
believe that light is always at 90
degrees or perpendicular to the the
surface
oh God yeah that's interesting yeah it's
one of those one of those things where
it's like it's such an interesting
phenomenon it's like cool how does that
happen or like seeing how people are
getting freaked out over it and then you
start looking at how people are
explaining it and you're like oh my God
like the theories that start rolling
through are just like
[__] bananas it's always that the
quiet part that's that's not said that
you start to worry about it's like how
are you explaining that but this is the
benefit this is what makes Modern Life
more interesting because science has
made it too boring as we'll talk about
[__] science you know what is it
Dominic it's done we have everything now
we have social media how do magnets work
as in saying Clown Posse asked
the famous question
how do magnets work I took physics 12 or
whatever and I know there's like
certain elements that have missing
electron whatever and then if they're
facing the right direction then it has a
polls but I don't know [__] Magnets
oh there's a parallel universe much like
the mirror world where but everything
just goes in the opposite directions and
when things get crossed over there's
magnetism when the when the boundaries
between the world start to thin out
there's there's my new Theory
this is good this is better than the
probably the actual explanation it's
like those uh the symposiums the
symposia excuse me when the the drunk
the drunk Upper Crust of Athenian
society would just come up with
explanations for things like love
we all used to be
giant fat two-part creatures and
everyone's looking for their other half
this is kind of actually interesting as
it does get to the topic of LaTour
pre-modern peoples
just like us because we've never been
modern
science is never on its own discovering
facts and [__] which is sort of a
supposition that maybe some scientists
but mostly people that don't really do
science but like to talk about it like
uh I don't know Neil deGrasse Tyson
types thinks science just answers
questions and facts and discovers things
and [__] like that so if you look at the
real world and you look at covid look at
global warming
actually we had the hottest day in
recorded history this week I think yeah
I think I saw that highest average
temperatures ever recorded on Earth yeah
we don't want to we don't want to do
that woke [__] hail in a handbasket he
talks about climate change here too
which is very surprising it's like a
persistent theme
because the first climate change
conference happened in 1989 which is an
important date well as we'll see but uh
yeah yeah he's talking about uh
climate change the because he wants to
connect everything right ozone layer to
Scientific labs to politics to
to scientists
and he brings in all these all these
different elements yeah
yeah basically saying that there's no
private objective Island that science
happens on that separate from everything
else so like we make and you can expect
us to make covid is not a scientific
issue it's a political issue as well at
the same time it's a matter of concern
same thing with uh global warming it's
funny that global warming is being
called woke now
anyway that's where we are our actual
topic today as we said we were never
modern but we have to before we actually
get to the content of the book talk
about the science Wars which I know is
something you are an expert on as well
shut up and let you talk about it but
when we're speaking of infectious
diseases I want to set you up here
because I always remember this anecdote
uh from Alan SoCal and if you don't know
listener if you don't know uh SoCal
he
is the guy who proved that critical
theorists are all intellectual imposters
and we don't actually know anything yeah
through the SoCal Affair when he was
able to publish some complete gibberish
articles in presumably critical theorist
magazines but I don't want to go too
much into that because at the same time
as this was happening
so Kyle had enough had an opinion on
Bruno LaTour
and he called him this is not verbatim
but it basically called him a [__]
because there was some pharaoh who died
uh so it was a mummy but the Pharaoh
they tested on the pharaoh's body
and they found
tuberculosis or whatever signs of
tuberculosis are
um and then said okay this pharaoh
probably a ram Aziz I'm not sure but the
Pharaoh died of uh tuberculosis and uh
LaTour responds to this
humorously saying like it's impossible
for someone to die from a disease that
was invented in the 19th century and so
Carl I think so Cal is a scientist or or
some stem thing but he was very
indignant because the scientists had
done tests on the mummy and found out
that there was tuberculosis in it so
it's proved and this post-modern
neo-marxist is out here saying he didn't
die from tuberculosis because
tuberculosis was invented in the 19th
century so I'd like it if you could
I'm sure there's people who are
sympathetic love like of course he died
from tuberculosis why from Bruno
latour's perspective can you say that
something that has existed for so long
was invented when it was discovered yeah
yeah it's such a it's such a weird thing
to say when you don't know where he's
coming from because I guess
uh Alan so calls a mathematician and his
in his co-author on the famous book
fashionable nonsense
uh jean-brick Moses co-author Belgian
theoretical physicist
so these two hard scientists did a big
takedown of all the ways that newfangled
postmodern theorists are
adopting the language of Science and and
and and subverting it and using it in in
ways that are not consistent with I
guess it's mathematical elaborations and
it's theoretical physical acceptations
uh so they wrote a big Angry reactionary
book about it and an accused uh I I
guess you'd accuse in that case you'd
accuse um him of being of not believing
in reality he's got that question before
so it's like well if what really killed
this Pharaoh is tuberculosis then how
can we say that he didn't die of
tuberculosis uh well the answer is I
guess I guess you have to understand
what he means by it tuberculosis hadn't
been invented yet sometimes he uses the
word uh invented discovered in in a
hyphenated fashion
because when you
you know it's a really complicated thing
to diagnose a disease right you don't
see tuberculosis or you don't see a
disease you see a set of symptoms and it
might share
with other diseases right and
today we've isolated tuberculosis or
that happened in the 19th century I
think and then we can start to look at
history
and develop more techniques right
because we've got to develop
archaeological techniques to excavate
these things we've got to develop
microscopes and the right tools to do it
we need Laboratories we need funding we
need all these sorts of things to be in
place before tuberculosis can be a thing
tuberculosis wasn't just like an idea
floating around that some Egyptian
pharaoh caught one day and then
tuberculosis was a thing so you have to
understand it as a kind of network
effort you know the history of
tuberculosis started with the Egyptians
and ended and I guess it was like a long
berth and it was finally born in the
19th century but the the labor pains
took a few thousand years you could
probably look at it that way maybe a
little more neutrally
so there are facts I don't think anyone
is denying that
but the fact has all these tendrils that
is produced at the end of a process and
to say okay this fact has now arrived it
has no history it has no social context
and we can use this fact on its own as
distinct from that I guess it's an
artificial way to think about a
knowledge process is that that what
you'd think is is happening here I mean
you can say it's it's good short form to
say yeah he died of tuberculosis but
when you look at the way that scientific
facts are actually established
there's so much complexity there that
that
LaTour wants us to slow down and Trace
these networks in detail rather than
just kind of flattening them all out
brushing them aside and and just jumping
to the final product which is
tuberculosis has always existed or at
least has always existed or at least
came to be in the last 300 000 years of
human history or something like that
right another way to phrase it might be
to ask the question of whether knowledge
is produced over time by accidents and
contingencies or whether knowledge
itself is just a reflection of the world
as it is yeah you have to look at it as
a network
and you have to look at it in terms of
all of these different things that are
in play and there's no one it goes back
to what you were saying right we we
think we think people make discoveries
and inventions in isolation it's like
you know we have this individualist
theory of History just like we have an
individualist theory of science right
did did Newton
all on his own straight out of his own
brain come up with the things he did now
Nikola Tesla helped him along right and
I'm sure there's a many other uncredited
computers Newton and Tesla are not
contemporary sorry Edison Edison Edison
I misspoke yeah and I'm sure there's a
whole load of unnamed men and women who
are involved in that process but we take
all that away and we attribute it to you
know Edison
and we're doing the same thing we're
taking all that effort and History of
Science and Discovery and everything
we're just removing all of this
nature culture political imbroglios
we're we're erasing all of that and just
jumping to the saying he has
tuberculosis well how does he have it
well
and how do we know and that you can sort
of then start maybe tracing it backwards
and and getting away from that but you
know it's that flattening out of this
complicated
networky system of discovery that I
think he's most concerned with so of
course he believes in reality of course
he believes that when we are talking
about tuberculosis we are talking about
tuberculosis itself and not a
representation in discourse not a
cultural idea we're talking about a real
thing
but it's about how facts are made how
facts are forged and the the efforts
that go into you know establishing
something as a fact it's not like
someone discovers something in a lab and
then boom it's Universal human knowledge
no there's there's a process of of
generalization and and and and
distribution of this information there's
peer review there's all kinds of things
right and again it goes not just the
scientific side but socially politically
economically
and that's what I mean that's I guess
his efforts to bring us to attend to
those sorts of things makes him make
statements like that that sound really
weird
um I mean we have to say he's being
intentionally provocative of course but
the provocation is to draw attention to
the fact that calling something in
whatever third millennium BC calling it
tuberculosis is an anachronism but in
the anachronism itself we're flattening
out every type of reality including
matters of concern which is another one
of his terms but things that people care
about we're flattening it all too
there's one real world and then there's
all the fake stuff on top of it the fake
stuff is what humans are interested in
maybe we call it subjective as opposed
to objective which is one of those
dualities that we can ever uh seem to
get rid of yeah like these the
modernists are very happy to say the
Egyptians were wrong
a fact as a fact for all time is the
thing that is
being uh prodded at here because we can
say only from our particular perspective
once tuberculosis has been uh discovered
but it's also been constructed at the
same time there is obviously what is
tuberculosis is it germs
all right yeah I guess it's a bacterial
lung infection yeah whatever it is that
thing is real but it has no causal
efficacy until it has gone through a
process of being named being established
being considered at this point a fact
and today it is a fact but then to say
he died from it
while that is true in the medical sense
it's also separating tuberculosis from
the network that produced tuberculosis
as a as a knowledge object including the
production of presumably what's a pretty
accurate method of what's ever required
to pull apart a mummy and do tests on
its its tissues and rule out every other
option yeah like we want to get behind
these facts and see how they are
produced and and not just take them for
granted right not not just the facts
themselves with the process of
you know making something a fact or
confirming that something is indeed a
fact and and confirming that something's
not a fact you know the work that goes
into that kind of thing is is incredible
and it's it's it it's kind of like you
know there's there's a few different
angles too right like if you're an
anthropologist and and LaTour and and
his Co co-authors and and his his cohort
very influenced by anthropology so what
if what about what what did the
Egyptians think about how
this person died like how did how did
tuberculosis if it was endemic in Egypt
how did it fit into their culture how
did they respond to it how do they shape
it and like you can you you also ignore
all these questions you know it's that
classic thing right the moderns like
SoCal think that the Ancients are
misguided and eventually modern science
wins out over ancient Superstition and
that's kind of been the story of the
last 250 300 years of progress right the
modern ways are displacing the ancient
ways right you know tuberculosis is in
nature so whatever culture thinks about
nature is irrelevant because culture is
a separate sphere that has nothing to do
with nature or it's something we can
clearly and distinguish
right and that's the he wants to flip
all this upside down cool he wants to
turn this up around and get behind
what's going on here with these this
this modernism
so how do we get under facts because
they can be got under
um but if we are never modern
what is what does it mean to be modern
we talk about we usually talk about
post-modern and I often refer to
modernism as a shorthand but if we are
never modern
let's just well how do we even do this
first people we're doing Dark Age [__]
whatever they were doing they were doing
philosophy they were doing primitive
philosophy like Thomas Aquinas who is
just a monkey with a typewriter and done
scoted you know done scotus actually
gets citations but I don't think I've
ever seen anyone who has not like a
Catholic site Aquinas in my life yeah
I have tried to read him I think in
undergrad but he's like
first of all he's the most boring guy to
have ever written anything which the
stories confirm oh Scholastics in
general are a bit like that well you
know even in his life you know his his
Bros hired a a hooker and locked her in
a room with him so that he would get
laid but he he like chased her off with
a fire poker because he didn't want to
lose his virginity so then just sat in a
room and read Aristotle his entire life
anyway there you go there's a portrait
that is that is pre-modernism yeah and
then modernity is Descartes coming in to
sweep the floor and say how do I really
know if I'm sweeping the floor uh or if
I'm Dreaming but by the way God is also
real
and then you get the Russo and you get
the Kant and we were modern until I
guess leotard said that hey we're not
really modern anymore
but this is this is an interesting
thesis here because you can't be
post-modern if we've never been modern
so modern here obviously uh explains a
method of thought and thought about
thought I'd say and it doesn't suck too
so modern thought as opposed to
traditional thought traditional thought
is flawed not evidence-based modern
thought uh we move away from tradition
Descartes to Nature Descartes always the
punching bag
yeah yeah and his his you know his
substance dualism right that's kind of a
early version of of what's going on here
this this conceits that we have never
been modern yeah it's very much in in
the vein of anti-cartesian thinking
where we don't want a mind-body dualism
or even kind of
anti-kantian thinking where we don't
want to have a kind of transcendental
subjectivity
through which the world is is filtered
and you can never get to the thing in
itself whatever the hell that is if
really ever said anything like that
about the thing in itself who knows but
that's kind of become the well a lot of
people know but that's become the uh
kind of firm position of cons and
popular philosophies that he's he said
we cannot know or touch or ever get to
the thing in itself which he never said
but
the reason I think that uh probably
Bruno the tour is up at number 10 on
this citation list is because he's here
uh deconstructing well I mean not there
not there at a deconstructing but uh
investigating will say the subject
object Duality and then right Downstream
from subject object Duality is the
nature culture Duality so you've
probably heard this before because this
is one of those like
critical theory sins that is super bad
you're not supposed to do the subject
object Duality that's a if you do you're
a bad person that's a bad Descartes
thing you're promoting a reactionary
position
you're a modernist I don't know you
probably do this in like fourth year
undergrad and certainly in any graduate
seminar you're gonna you're gonna run
into the sin of the subject object
Duality but uh that's kind of what
LaTour is is producing here uh just
demonstrating how hard it is to actually
come to what we call in shorthand a
scientific fact and how long the process
is and how many people are involved in
the process and then we get the end
result and then treat it almost as a as
if that social aspect of the political
aspect of the fact never happen yeah and
we should say too we're giving you kind
of the conclusion of his arguments where
if you actually like read his his
writing he does this he does this with
like uh pasteurization for example how
pasteurization got produced yeah and and
it's it's an interesting book to get
into because you see seems to start he
really starts this book on a in a very
like in a defensive Crouch basically
like he's talking about critics he's
he's anticipating uh incomprehensibility
towards what he's talking about right
now basically he's just anticipating
that if if what he's saying can't be
divided into you know nice disciplinary
containers right sociologists study
these things and not those things
because those things are for the are for
the scientists and and and but they
don't study how science works that's for
the science studies people right so we
have these separate compartments right
and and he starts in a defensive Crouch
saying well the way I'm going to talk
about this is uh I'm going to link
across these
these divisions I don't care these
separations I'm going to link across
them and he starts I wish I could read
newspapers like the tour can it's it's
really funny he starts off with like
reading a bunch of just a just him
reading a newspaper and he talks about
all these different things that these
stories are bringing together all these
different
actors things people institutions
they're all weaving together in these
stories he's just like on page four of
my daily newspaper I learned that the
measurements taken above the Antarctic
are not good this year the hole in the
ozone layer is getting bigger reading on
I turn from the upper atmosphere to
uh to the Chief Executive Officer of uh
atochem and Monsanto so we're bringing
in these companies now monsanto's got a
nasty reputation there and then he
starts talking about chlorofluorocarbons
crimes against the ecosphere then we get
into moral and political debates and so
he he's he weaves all these things
together and he says this is this is the
way that science studies should work is
we shouldn't you know break these things
off such that the measurements of the
ozone layer would be for the scientists
and nobody else you know Monsanto
whatever they do their economics we
don't deal with them they're regulated
by the politicians but the politicians
aren't scientists so they need translate
you see what I mean it's always
difficult to it's a little difficult to
key in
to his style of thought because of this
kind of I I can't help but think this is
this is rhizomatic right these are
rhizomes when he says Network I hear
rhizome when he says thread I hear line
of flight right all these different ways
through something that don't that ignore
these I mean in this case disciplinary
divisions
and he uses the analogy of ariadne's
thread to what these stories are doing
they're threading together all of these
different aspects and ariadne's famously
the the
the ancient Greek princess who Theseus
who helped Theseus get back out of the
labyrinth after
um killing the Minotaur and then and
then he abandoned her on the island of
naxos and [__] off
um not a very thankful or good guy but I
mean that's that's who she is but this
thread is the metaphor here and so the
threads a single thread links the most
esoteric sciences and the most sordid
Politics the most distant sky and some
Factory in the Leon suburbs dangers on a
global scale and the impending local
elections or the next board meeting I
think that was a quote so he's he's
weaving together these things using the
metaphor of the thread
which is like with newspaper stories are
doing you could go through today's uh
democracy now and look at oh nuclear
plant in Ukraine oh a uh the the head of
a Russian hired military paramilitary
organization politics in the East Biden
is in Sweden right now doing something
like you know all these different things
what's going on in Sweden oh they're
trying to build join NATO but people are
burning qurans and and Iranians are
getting pissed off and so now you have
religion in there too like there's you
know he's he's doing this sort of thing
he's he's trying to like methodologize
that's not a word but now it is he's
trying to put a method to these things
which we're going to eventually know as
actor Network Theory or ant for short
but that doesn't come until a bit later
but this book kind of just
just breaks the ground for that and this
is the problem I'm not really sure who
he's attacking because it it seems like
the things that he has is writing here
have been things that have you know
gained notoriety and popularity and we
like things like oh yeah multi
multi-disciplinarity and all that stuff
so I it the context seems a little
foreign because of how defensive he
starts but basically
um you don't cut off I think the people
that he's probably attacking are
pop scientists you know the scientists
that are not really scientists but they
come out and go look everyone there are
scientific facts you can't debate these
things and the the pop scientists aren't
having a good go-around in our day
because of tick tock like how do mirrors
work how do mirrors see soon are going
to have an entirely new uh competitive
apparatus for explanations of phenomenon
that the pop scientists they're just
they're too boring to compete with
frankly who wants to hear about the fact
that light can reflect when you can
consider consider the alternative
hypothesis that the Mirror Universe
where we have we have locked them in we
have locked them into only repeating our
actions forever but they're abiding
their time until they will have revenge
and emerge from the mirrors and take
over reality Prime yeah this is like a a
bit of politics in here or two with the
book because of this I think some of his
critics are also like disciplinarian
academics too like old school
disciplinary and academics like the type
like like Roger Dawkins right you can't
say anything new about genetics because
you're wrong because he already figured
it all out all we needed was Darwin and
then Mendel and then we just needed
modern mathematics and computers and
then we got Darwin and that's the end of
the story if you say anything about
symbiote Genesis your uh communist freak
yeah Roger Dawkins is the uh the mirror
verse the mirror World version of
Richard Dawkins
and somehow he's even worse
but no uh this is this is to say we
can't separate here's all the human
stuff on one side human stuff it's
confusing people are idiots they do a
bunch of random [__] and who knows what
they're gonna do but then over here we
have our little island of science
science is based on facts and these two
worlds are separate so his way of
separating it I mean we're prefacing
actor Network Theory but the tour wants
to treat all these different things that
we're bringing up as actants I think is
is his term for it
that's the actor in the actor Network
Theory so if we want to have a theory of
how science came to be what it is or
anything else for that matter you have
to just look at actins and the network
that they're a part of so an individual
person could be an actant
so can uh
tuberculosis tuberculosis is enactant
um an idea can be an actant a religion
interpreting a specific idea can be an
actant and you're not going to get an
actual picture of how whatever final
truth emerges because a final truth is
never going to ultimately emerge but
you're never going to have a picture of
how this rhizome is is running into
itself and reconnecting and making
different connections and in some cases
being cut off
like maybe with uh
I don't know cloning just tons of laws
against cloning so in that case the the
state would be some sort of actent and
the people who want to do cloning and
say you know science for science sake
that's a a type of acting yeah so anyway
we have all these actants in all these
networks they're competing they're
fighting for energy they're fighting for
resources they're encouraging each other
sometimes fighting against each other at
other times and to treat science as its
own private island
like a lot of uh stem types would like
to think it is that's just not what
happens and if you look back if you take
a historical perspective of is what
modernity is modernity is to look at
history and to explain away the
complexity and give a simple explanation
in the modern period we replaced Aquinas
and tradition and primitive animism and
so on I mean I'm still going to use the
term modernity but to use the term
modernity is to reproduce something very
low fidelity
because low Fidelity is easier to draw
Grand conclusions about and actor
Network theory is
I don't know attempting to produce some
High Fidelity picture which is a lot
more work yeah that thread just to carry
on with that thread metaphor a bit
since it kind of opens the book and it
it kind of
puts it in this way if if well who's
cutting the gordian knot here well well
life is like I guess he's just this is
like almost like a theory of of of of
what is like with tangled threads
forming a kind of gordian knot right
everything is all mixed together life is
messy he calls it actually as funny um
another another STS John Law calls it a
mess instead of a network acronym drop
sorry uh science technology and Society
or just science studies for short that's
the kind of just a shorthand for like
what LaTour is doing in science studies
he did his he did his earlier work in
Loot on Louis Pasteur and the invention
discovery of the pasteurization process
because surely pasteurization has always
been around but just nobody's ever done
it but it's always existed right yeah
Rick yeah yeah brickmont you're right
about that now so he did this early work
on that these are the science studies
people he went into he looked at lab
reports he read the words of Pastor and
he traced all the connections and
political and everything else whatever
so he he calls all this like a knot
right he actually did field work too
yeah yeah he's like in Africa
which is again again to show that you
know theorists who want to sit around
and theorize always end up coming with
simple pictures and he's arguing for a
complicated picture that takes work ew
yeah and like these kinds of these kinds
of people they'll study
um objects it's it's a kind of
object-oriented or material culture
oriented sort of study so yeah he
latours some of his early works on Louis
Pasteur and the anthrax bacterium
um some Michelle callon another famous
one here's the example he did fuel cell
electrodes and so you just take this
sort of thing whatever it is and you
trace all the all the connections it
runs through all the different spheres
that it's I don't know journey through
existence takes it into instead of
dividing it into separate spheres into
disciplinary silos because is that's
cutting the gordian knot right this what
he says they they cut the gordian knot
with a well-honed sword the shaft is
broken on the left they have put
knowledge of things on the right power
and human politics you cut the gordian
knot and you sort things into those two
containers so you'll call them he in in
in his later work he he comes up with
another analogy this is like describing
a war and you start with all the guns
and equipment on the one side and all
the naked soldiers on the other side and
you proceed to dialectically relate them
together and that's how you describe a
war when you have cut the gordian knot
right and he says no me and my friends
we want to re-tie the gordian knot and
he says quote here retie the gordian
knot by crisscrossing as often as we
have to the divide that separates exact
knowledge in the exercise of power let
us say nature and culture right he this
is his method of translation and I can
sorry I'm I'm going on but I can
illustrate this really well with a stop
sign right a stop sign is a cultural
thing it's a sign you have to know what
it means you have to be from that
culture you have to be socialized you
have to know what it means but you can
ignore that stop sign [__] it lots of
people do blow through it [__] it so how
do you get how do you translate from
culture to uh nature or a material thing
you put us you put a sleeping policeman
there as they call them in England you
put a speed bump and now you've you've
translated this imperative to stop this
cultural imperative this this meaningful
sign that you should stop here into a
more coercive method of if you run this
if you run past this you will ruin your
car's suspension and have a big Bill at
the mechanic and so he this is his you
know that's what he's saying here I'm
going to crisscross between knowledge of
things and exercises of power right we
have to have knowledge of the stop sign
the culture side we have to have the
power to stop people and you can put
that on the material side with the speed
bump put on the cultural side with the
please stop here sir this thing request
you can do it that way it's so he's you
know he talks about door hinges he's all
over the place with this stuff but this
is his his strategy right translation
between those kinds of
trying to re-tie the gordian knot in
that way and and acknowledge the I mean
he doesn't like these words but like the
complexity or the systematicity of life
well even if even if I accept your
premise here Eric LaTour
surely there has always been
tuberculosis we just didn't know that
there was why would you call this an
invention
and say that
someone didn't die of tuberculosis when
we have evidence that they did how are
you how are you helping here well
another thing you could look at is you
could look at tuberculosis as an event
right you could look at it as an event
s take place at at greater or slower
speeds greater or lesser speeds and the
discovery of tuberculosis just took
thousands and thousands of years it's an
event it happened it started maybe with
this ancient Egyptian pharaoh maybe
earlier and it was completed maybe still
kind of ongoing because we're still
dealing with tuberculosis unfortunately
so maybe that event actually hasn't
reached its horizon yet but that's
Whitehead philosophy which LaTour is
extremely influenced by and that might
be another way to look at it look into a
little bit into his influences in that
way
instead of cutting it up again and
saying you know what the Egyptian
thought about it that's the job of the
archaeologists and anthropologists what
it is that's the job of the scientists
what we do about it now that it's been
discovered that's the job of the
politicians there you go nice neat
divide right cut the gordian knot sorted
out into those little containers neat
and tidy we can understand it now and
that's why he's against his critics
right saying they're not going to
understand this and the reason is they
are
addicted to the modernist settlement as
he calls it this modernist Constitution
where you have what like I said nature
on one side non-humans on that side too
and you have humans and culture and
politics and Power on the other side
okay and that's that's the problemo he's
trying to deal with he's trying to
re-tie that knot
so if we have someone
I'm trying to provoke you here a little
bit if we have someone like uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson who goes you know people
can be at War they can be fighting they
can be funding it doesn't matter if
they're doing any of those things or not
we know that there are facts we know
that there are
electrons why does it matter what all
those people are doing if we are just
scientists and we only just care about
what these electrons are doing and we
want to
have a theory of magnetism or something
like that why do we need to know all the
rest of that [__] yeah theory of
magnetism and the rest of that [__] well
I guess you want to know
the motivations behind the theory of
magnetism right I mean you could just if
you just break off a little piece and
look at say
science and politics just forget about
all the other things for a second say
science and politics you know they're
supposed to be completely separate
things right science isn't influence by
politics and politics
kind of uses science in a practical way
but isn't sort of interested in its
theoretical side
it's basically separate they don't
influence each other right so he he
wants to blow this view out of the water
completely
any
I'm not going to be able to find the
quote quickly that rebuts that
but yeah I mean what about the
motivations behind doing this research
in the first place what about the
funding who who funded it right did they
think they were going to make a profit
or was it a public funded thing if it
was public funded was it paid for by
taxes did you get people to agree to it
and of course that has nothing to do
with magnetism itself
but this is the method this is the
method right when you
cut that gordian knot as I was saying
you sort of make things a little bit
incomprehensible
I don't know in the sense that we
we we live our lives in these
extraordinarily complicated tangled up
situations and our disciplines give us
an image of the world that's just like
neat and tidy and has everything has its
place
and we got to get rid of that view
because it is holding us back
yeah speaking of we have this uh op the
Oppenheimer movie is
coming out soon would we have discovered
I mean for sure it's a fact there's no
way that we would have discovered uh
nuclear fission at the rate and speed at
which we did if we're not at War
and I say we I don't know why I say we
but Manhattan Project Oppenheimer all
that [__] tons of funding he's like
you just have to say you know what if
you give me a shitload of money I'm
gonna be able to make a bigger bomb than
any bombs you guys have and they go okay
sure
so this was bringing back to mind the
thought that I have of where this
matters how do you how do you interject
this so we have archaeological facts
like okay at some point we moved from
the Bronze Age to the Iron Age and this
is one of those low Fidelity stories
that we're referring to earlier a low
Fidelity story that there's like these
brackets on history
and there's a shift
and we can like pinpoint a a time in
which this shift happened and it's so
vague as to like how do you evaluate its
truth when you're when you're talking
about something so vaguely and last or
when we were talking about the David
Graber book The Dawn of everything
sorry The Davids
the the first name but when grows we
can't forget about wengro anyway we have
we have iron and what I found striking
about the
the explanation of the iron thing is if
we have the Age of Empire's view of
History it's like people are constantly
at War constantly going out and trying
to find better ways to kill each other
but with the invention of iron which
comes from mining
but I mean again sorry invention not
really but Discovery or use of iron
first you have to have a lot of irons
around why was there a lot of iron
around because of mining why were they
mining because they wanted to dye their
clothes
but if you take it if you take a fact
like oh humans are a war-like species
they're always comp or same with
gunpowder right gunpowder was invented
thousands of years ago not used as
gunpowder it wasn't used for guns it was
used for fireworks so if you take a fact
and try to isolate it from the context
then you can draw these conclusions like
humans are constantly in a war of all
against all trying to kill each other
every time they discover something it's
with the intent to kill each other when
in you discover these these things that
define ages of warfare and it turns out
no people wanted to dye clothes and make
fireworks and that gives you a
completely different overall picture of
what you're using
a a fact
to prove and in this case it would be
something like uh an archaeological
record when you look at the record and
the fact with its Network
people are vain people care about
clothes they care about the color of
their clothes they care about parties
fireworks and then you get a very
different picture from oh we needed to
find something to kill each other better
and that's why iron became important to
human civilization or that's why
gunpowder came to be important to
civilization if you put it in the
network you're going to get a very
different picture than you would if you
start with basically a conclusion and
then apply the facts to it yeah now as
opposed to iron and as opposed to
Gunpowder the Manhattan Project was the
kind of thing where it was a conscious
decision to fund to discover to do
experiments with the express purpose
that you know if you give us this much
money we can help you win the war and
kill as many people in as horrifying
away as possible but to say that that is
why science is done of course would be
one of those
those stories that isn't true in most
cases
and I I mean it's it's even yeah he kind
of blames this on the philosophers of
science too for making such a um how
does he how does he describe it a a
sacred a Sacred Space out of um out of
facts if the like uh you know so we so
let's say I was just talking about or we
were just talking about various things
and then we we maybe scientific facts
and then we start talking about politics
and then the critic goes but hold on
hold on you're not talking about science
then you're talking about politics
you're reducing scientific truth to Mere
political interests that's what I've
done I've said what about the
motivations behind the atom bomb or
something right it's War you were saying
or something like that right well you're
just reducing it to political interests
here's the here's a another
misunderstanding if the facts and here's
the sort of warrant for this if the
facts do not occupy the simultaneously
marginal and sacred place of our worship
is reserved for them then it seems that
they are immediately reduced to Pure
local contingency in sterile
machinations yet science studies are
talking not about the social context in
the interests of power but about their
involvement with collectives and objects
that's right the the social context
interests of power not about them but
about their involvement with collectives
and and Collective here is is the better
term for social because social just
means humans collectives means a
collective of humans and non-humans now
if you're in your room alone and you
think you're a social being and look
around you and see if there are more
humans or things around you right I live
alone and I'm constantly Michael my
Collective is quite populated but
there's not too many humans here except
virtually when I do this but you know
that's one of the misunderstandings that
again these critics are reading their
their works because presumably he's
they've all published things and
received these kinds of critic critiques
and now Bruno LaTour is writing this new
book we have never been modern to try
and like take these things head on
because they're getting a bit out of
control
and he says yeah so once you go in to
start talking about politics then
you're just you're you're relating it to
collectives and objects he says he says
I will use the word he says here
Collective to describe the association
of humans and non-humans and I'll use
Society to designate one part of our
collectives
The Divide invented by the social
sciences right and that that word you
should you should hear an echo in it
because it's it's it's never clear until
a second reading which words are
important and Bruno latur because he
doesn't highlight all of them
Association you hear that word social in
there right Association is an active
thing that you do on a daily basis
that's what keeps Society going this is
society is not like the social isn't
just like a a metaphysical glue that
holds us all together right this
associative networks are networks that
we maintain in the same way that he
would say a baboon tribe on a daily
basis reaffirms hierarchies it tests the
boundaries it tries to get the mates it
wants and it gets smacked down it tries
to do this you know they're constantly
reaffirming their social media it's not
a thing that's just taken for granted
and existing there behind us like some
kind of magical
threads that tie us all together now
these things take work to to maintain
and preserve and if we don't do that
they'll fall apart or they'll change on
us
and we don't want that the context and
the technical content turn out to be
redefined every time he says so that's
this is rebut his rebuff to that kind of
thing is saying well you're not talking
about science anymore you're talking
about politics well no I'm not I'm
talking about how they're involved in
collectives and with objects right
objects things the other half of the
collective that's not society that we
always always always forget about I mean
what would Society be without cell
phones
computers would be a lot different right
not just like I guess when the radio
came out people like what would Society
be without the radio I'm inventing a
magical box that can receive invisible
signals from miles away that sounds like
insanity
here it is it's called a radio so I want
to turn this because it looks like a lot
of the attack is at science Island you
know
but really exactly the same critique of
separating and uh like putting your
discipline outside of all of these other
matters of concern applies also to
philosophy
and it applies also to political Theory
where the disciplines sort of before
they even start Purge
on purpose or just by continuing for
contingent reasons they Purge their
discipline of all the things that they
don't want to look at so for philosophy
you might call it we want to look at
ideas in the history of ideas for
political Theory we want to look at
what we think is the ideal organization
of a group of people
and we're just going to engage with the
history of people who discussed or
different organizations of people but I
guess an out an actor Network theory of
any discipline
must be really hesitant to leave
anything out which makes it again a lot
of work it's it's saying you can never
isolate the object of your inquiry you
can't just talk purely about ideas you
cannot talk purely about uh humans as if
they exist in a vacuum without any of
the other [__] that humans have around
them so this would just
I think
would just give you a much more
interesting picture of reality if you
start from Network so even a a highway
Network how has highways shaped American
society
because you can definitely see that it
has the arrangement of people where
people have settled why we have roads
here why we don't have roads here the
highways system in North America as
opposed to the hot the European lack
thereof highway system it creates a
different uh sense of sociality it
creates different Regional relative
power differentials it creates uh
different genres of film just having a
highway system so
yeah I I don't know this is coming out
of my ass but you know what if you just
a what if what if you started your
political Theory
using the the materiality of Highways
rather than starting with
uh the theoretical question of what is
the best organization of humans yeah and
we all kind of have that idea that the
highways have a kind of military origin
too
yeah they were at least in America they
were built out of like concrete so that
tanks could drive on them if it was ever
required
yeah the Canadian National Railway was
being built in the early 20th century
through the Prairies and then they
started calling people over to live
there and they wanted like Polish people
and and people like central eastern
European and and um and English to come
and populate these prairies because they
needed people out there to make the CNR
worth building further
and then and and then that stopped and
then when that became a problem well
guess we're a documentary filmmaking was
invented in Canada guess what one of his
first uses was to go get people from
Europe to live here and make they made
nice little videos of of I don't know
the Canadian wilderness and kind of
prairie life and a kind of idyllic
except no scenes of snow that was a rule
with these early ones no snow scenes and
then they they shipped them off to
England and showed them in the theaters
and and and people saw them and and then
they were actually offered a stipend of
land if they would just come move here
and then it turns out is really [__]
boring for them to live out in the
Prairies and be isolated from their
communities but anyway like that's just
another
I didn't know that that's cool
documentary film propaganda that is a
socio-technical imbroglio yeah but we
need people
well we need white people really so how
do we get white people
we create technological objects
and send them back to where white people
are to seduce them to move to
Saskatchewan
hopefully they survive the winner yeah
and then soon after that we had the
national film Board of Canada which is
super famous about one kilometer from
this location so this is I guess to say
there are no neutral facts is that a a
good summary yeah there are no there are
no isolated facts I I would say there's
no there's no such thing as an isolated
fact
everything exists in these networks
right everything is relative everything
is relational
you can think of these networks as
networks of relations but the relations
are not secondary to the things that are
related they are actually integral to
the terms of the relations
so a fact about a thing points to a
relation
actually you know on the topic of what
is a fact my boy Charles Sanders purse
has a really good definition of a fact
he says a relation is a fact about a
number of things thus the fact that a
locomotive blows off steam constitutes a
relation or more accurately a
relationship
between the locomotive and the steam in
reality every fact is a relation
thus that an object is blue consists in
the peculiar regular action that the
object has on human eyes
this is what should be understood by the
relativity of knowledge
all facts end quote in other words all
facts are relations and all knowledge is
relative but not in the cultural
relative sense but in the in the network
sense
right and I just heard a thousand people
have an aneurysm these people you know
when I when I say these people I mean
because you said the word the bad word
relativism
I should probably think through a type
of person this is but they're sort of a
conservative not even a political
conservative but a broad view
intellectual type person
with this conservative Viewpoint they
probably read New Yorker magazine or
like TED talks but relativism for them
is sinful and you know what I don't know
why it's sinful even in the academic
philosophy writing that corresponds to
this position that I've read
lately relativism is just not an option
it it can't be done because somehow it's
morally stinky
so it's theoretically theoretically
acceptable or even responsible to just
find a position that you can call
relativism and then dismiss it out of
hand and replace it with your new
meta Theory or whatever just go away
okay relativism relativism just means
that the closer that you look at things
the more relations you find not
whatever truth atoms anyway Eric I
wanted to ask you about the title one
more time what does it say to s or what
does it suggest to say
we've never been modern was that some
sort of fantasy that took over or how do
you read that title knowing the tour as
well as you do right so we have never
been modern so so we know about all the
different uh we know about modern mod
the moderns let's say and we know about
the prefixes that now go along with
modern right you mean like Post Yeah so
the way post and Auntie yeah so modern
modern is
um
well he defines it it he says the
adjective modern designates a new regime
an acceleration a rupture a revolution
in time
so one side on the one side of the
definition modern references the passage
of time
when the word modern modernization a
modernity appears we're defining by
contrast an archaic and stable past
the word is always being thrown into the
middle of a fight into a quarrel where
they're winners and losers ancients and
moderns right modern is thus a double
asymmetrical doubly asymmetrical a break
in time and combat where there are
Victors and vanquished losers and
winners whatever the moderns and the
Ancients we our knowledge is superior to
those who went before us modern in
introduces this double asymmetry and it
evolved over the ages you know probably
I don't know Descartes conflict with the
Scholastics right the moderns and the
Ancients right the ancient way of doing
things they co-existed by the way they
weren't ancients but they were you know
representing the old ways that's what
modern kind of does it makes people into
passe while they're still alive
so we have to rethink this definition
and what he goes through is is when we
start to lose trust in the in the
solidity of this disciplinary situation
it creates reactionary positions and he
calls them you know anti-modernists and
post-modernists or you could say
anti-modernist uh or reactionary
socialists who say let's just have
autocratic rule that's the way Zizek
seems to be going uh or we have
reactionary neoliberals who are just
like free market [__] everything else or
we get postmodern Skeptics who kind of
suspend facts between belief and doubts
in this weird space where you can't
really say it's true you can't really
say it's false because what do those
words mean anyway it's it's kind of
discursive those are meaning effects
that's a language game kind of thing so
you get these kinds of different
reactionary positions post modernism
anti-modernist conservatism and a kind
of in a kind of I don't know how he's
really fitting the mar the Marxist
picture in here but he's you know in
1989 follow the Berlin Wall first
climate change
conference follow the Berlin Wall freed
people from the tyranny of stalinism
and ironically then replaced the Elites
in back in the factories back into the
ownership positions they became
capitalists so we replaced tyranny with
domination and then every everyone's
happy right but no wait climate change
conference happens now the masses are
[__] because the the the the ecosystem
is no longer going to be sustaining
these people so they're going to be
progressively shifted into poverty so we
have this like kind of double movement
that's tearing apart our
our faith in the modern Constitution way
of doing things that maybe we do have to
look at politics and the climate and War
and and material substances as all
connected and not
divide them into these different
you know circuits and
then he'll go back and Trace the origin
of the modern Constitution to uh a
conflict between someone we spoke about
last week a little bit Hobbes and the
other guy not Rousseau but Boyle Robert
Boyle the guy who is I did so much
research on this because I wanted to
understand what was happening but we're
already like at the end of the episode
which sucks but
experiments on on air pumps and like
creating vacuums and then the effect of
vacuum so he's like putting or create a
vacuum
not a vacuum cleaner obviously but like
create a a space with no air in it and
then you'd put like bugs in there and be
like bugs can't fly and then try to find
all these uh
or or try to just describe for the first
time what air is which seems to us such
a foreign concept but they could do the
laboratory experiments
and then decide what air was but then
they had a whole a whole debate on what
the consensus means in terms of what do
we decide air is now that I've had my
laboratory conditions as opposed to
General conditions well the the short
version of it really is that
you know Hobbs and Boyle were both Cut
From the Same Cloth they're both really
into uh mechanical science like they
were mechanistic the mechanistic
materialism of the day
and they were both well here's a quote
they they agree on almost everything
they want a king a parliament a docile
and unified Church they are fervent
subscribers to mechanistic philosophy
okay so they agree on so many things
they're both thorough going rationalists
but their opinions diverge as to what
can be expected from experimentation
from scientific reasoning and from
political arguments so the politics guys
Hobbes but Hobbs did science and and the
science guys boil but Boyle was
interested in politics we tend to
overlook these things
um because
hobbes's science writings is bananas but
he was interested it really was
yeah uh and and and political theorists
who like Hobbes are kind of embarrassed
by it but the disagreements he says here
just to finish the disagreements between
the two men who agree on everything else
makes them the ideal laboratory material
the perfect fruit flies for the new
anthropology and that's what he's in
that so he's going to look at the way
that this division between politics and
science originates in in this in this
area that Hobbs and Boyle happened to
disagree upon which is the consequences
of experiment science and politics right
what like what consequences are they
going to have for society they disagreed
on what those consequences would be and
It ultimately ended up in this modern
Constitution where we have politics and
nature completely separate and and then
the tour next book I think is called the
politics of nature yeah he Pro he dives
into it more but um yeah and then these
days you have kind kind of Band-Aid
solutions to it which is like oh no we
should give oceans rights now we kind of
should give oceans rights but it's a
little late now and we don't consider
oceans to be like authentic beings so
anyway that let's split
was maintained but the split wasn't ever
actually maintained there was never
actually just a a full vacuum where
politics did not enter science and vice
versa yeah I mean the we have never been
modern thing is is really a lot like
this invention Discovery conundrum we
were we started with
is like if all of these problems are are
here but we we can trace them back to
their origin let's say Boyle and Hobbs
are exemplary figures in the origination
of this we can trace it back to its
origin we can point to the problems it's
causing
we can point to the reactions and how
insufficient they are he kind of
unfairly uses E.O Wilson this the
sociobiologist uh Borgia the sociologist
who focuses on the social and derida
who's a discourse textual oriented
philosophy uh he uses the he says if all
these kinds of reactions to
this this sort of lack of faith now in
the modern Constitution if all these
reactions fail we need something else
and and with that something else is is a
kind of anthropology that's attentive to
Politics as well and that
points Us in this direction and that
direction is
that division of time I mentioned
earlier if that collapses there were
really never ancients they were really
never moderns and there were only
networks of people you know
renegotiating their social contexts and
their technical apparatuses that's what
Hobbs and that's what Hobbes and uh
Boyle were doing they were they were
negotiating then and there their social
context social context didn't shape them
that's what I was saying earlier we're
not interested in how social context
shapes science right that's like you
know scientists are a product of their
social media blah blah blah that's old
hat science studies this new hat stuff
looks at the ways that the actors in The
situations negotiate their relationships
to their contexts so you're giving more
you know you're giving more to your
actors right you're you're you're
letting them
actually tell you what they think about
things and not just sort of ignoring
them a lot like condorunk and the uh and
those indigenous dialogues right where
you're you're not letting them speak
You're just assuming that they're
puppets for a European self-critique and
you erase their voices that's he's got a
a somewhat parallel argument here about
this and I mean on the strength of this
I mean it's it's just to say we we never
were modern in the first place this is a
completely
um
uh contingent and negotiated situation
and it's particularly durable it's
proven but it's not forever and we don't
need to you know be post-modernist if we
don't like modernism anymore then we
need to be uh Define ourselves as
um I don't know atheists against theism
we were never theists kind of thing
right well that's a good place to end it
on but I'm I am looking for like
considering Hobbs is batshit just
scientific theories that he was allowed
to come up with
the new site of the new science I hope
it's tick tock because
the world of tick tock has trolls and
angels and mirrors that have their own
uh private consciousnesses
and I really hope to to see some new
scientific theories emerge from there we
were never modern
hey oh all right with that we will uh
we'll rap we didn't get very far into
the text we got like nine pages in
I know I've got too many too many uh
anecdotes about my other readings from
the tour oh my God no it was good it was
good he's good though I like to hear it
beautiful prose all right uh if you want
to hear us talk more join our Network
become an actor in our Network on
patreon and that's it from us this week
yeah can't wait for the next embroglio
cheers
I'm gonna go make a mojito
peace everyone
foreign
[Music]